nobody loves talking about a baseball
scandal quite like Tom Verducci does
part of MLB network's ongoing coverage
to the Astros and now a Hall of Famer
Tom Verducci joining us in the program
good morning tom good morning
hall-of-famer thank you to the rumor
yourself that you started signing your
checks with an H oh no actually I sign
it Famer
I don't do HOF it's just a k-mer yes all
right thank you Tom and you too if I
told you a month ago this is where we
would be with the Astros you would have
said what I no way I didn't see first of
all the harshness of the penalties or
the fallout coming but once I read the
commissioners 9 page statement
concluding the investigation then I got
it in other words I thought that was so
transparent I thought they did a very
good job laying out exactly what
happened with the Astros then I
understood there's a lot of things I did
not know before for instance that they
stole them signs throughout the 2017
postseason the fact that Alex Cora was
such an integral part of that these are
the things we didn't know so I wasn't
expecting as much as we got all right
there's a couple of things there's a few
directions to go in but let me start
with Mike fiers who was with the Astros
now with the Oakland A's and I think he
might have told some of his new
teammates this is what the Astros did
and then he told Kenny Rosenthal and
then all of a sudden it went public here
but if fiers doesn't say this does
anybody you know is anybody disciplined
do we find out anything that went on
with the Astros in that postseason run I
think eventually then I think it sounded
like the athletic and I don't want to
speak for them was on the story and
pursuing it getting fires on the record
a member of that team obviously clinched
the deal they also talked with Danny
Farquhar as well the White Sox pitcher
but yeah I think eventually this was
going to come out you know there's just
there's so much movement in Major League
Baseball now I think actually 17 of the
players on that 17 Astros team are with
other organizations or retired now so I
think eventually
the thing was gonna come out but
obviously an active player on that team
admitting that that's what they were
doing yeah that was powerful why didn't
the commissioner go after the players
well you have to go back to his memo on
September 15 2017 when he first this is
after the Apple watch incident with the
Red Sox and Yankees where I think he
first woke up to the fact that people
were using technology and I think
rampantly to decode signs so there had
been no rules on the books about that in
terms of what the penalties would be he
changed that with a memo I put it he
sent out two front office and field
staff not two players the memo went out
to management people and basically said
you do this you're going to be punished
severely and I think his idea right then
was it's just so hard to get into the
muck and mire of trying to find out from
players who did what in that clubhouse
culture to what extent how would you
ever discipline them on an individual
basis so he said listen we came up with
this system this replay system we're the
ones that put the monitor down there so
it's up to our people management people
to make sure we have a culture where
it's not misused so the onus was on
management people right away it wasn't
like he decided when the ruling came out
that he would skirt players and I don't
know if there's a deterrent then Tom if
you're not going to punish them you're
afraid of the Players Union and you're
gonna basically punish the adults in in
the room here the players are in in the
clear yeah it's a great point dad
because hey there's so much
responsibility specifically on the
manager now think about that you're
managing a major league game trying to
in real time do what you need to do in
terms of the decisions and player
personnel now you're also responsible
for whatever is going on behind you in
the clubhouse in the video room whether
it's analysts back there or decoding
signs or players going back there to get
a peek that's on the manager none of the
people who are actually doing it so it's
a very special exemption it's a
carve-out in terms of player behavior in
other words you use peds you know you
cork your bet you put pints are in the
ball that's on you and you're going to
be punished for it but you now can steal
sighs electronically and not face any
punishment the manager the general
manager will
I understand why the Commissioner did
that because I don't think it's because
he's fearful of any kind of reprisal
from the Union in terms of grievance and
appeals I think is just so darn
difficult to cut that discipline for any
individual player yeah but that would be
like a writer plagiarizing something and
then the writers boss being punished for
what the writer did
yeah I'm agree with you I don't think
it's necessarily fair but I think it
from the practical point of view I'm not
sure where he could go with this I mean
what would you do right now say you were
going to punish Astros players what
would you do basically everybody on that
team knew what was going on and did
nothing about it including Mike fiers I
would vacated Tom I'd vacate the World
Series that then I punished the players
that's his that might be as close as I
get to a punishment that's a team
punishment and you know but again you're
not individually punishing players for
their behavior I get we are saying
there's you were officially putting a
taint but then that taint is there or
the team you know that I know that the
most precious thing all of us have is
our reputation and then reputation is
shot we're sitting here almost seventy
years later talking about the 1951
Giants as cheaters and we'll be talking
about the Astros 70 years from now as
cheaters so I don't think you needed the
Commissioner to say that the reputation
is broken yeah but it is how to vae a
Hall of Famer now I you know it's that's
going to be up to every individual voter
and I'm certainly one of them I'm not
gonna assess his candidacy right now but
it's something we all are now going to
have to grasp with there's no question
about that Beltran will be the first
list litmus test yeah I'd say he was a
first ballot slam-dunk hall-of-famer but
he certainly has Hall of Fame type
credentials would you in Federation if
you were the Mets would you have kept
him in I would not have I mean just
played out there if you wanted to keep
him he'd have to make a full accounting
of what he did at a press conference
there'd be a million questions about
when this began personally played for
the Yankees in the first three years
when replay monitors were down in the
dugout
did he just start with the Astros and 17
when the monitors were in place and 14
and 15 and 16 what did he do in the
World Series you know it wasn't going
away he would start
his term first term as a manager being
labeled as a cheater and someone who
lied to the media about his involvement
I mean that just destroys your
credibility at a time when let's face it
baseball needs it
Astros don't get the benefit of the
doubt so when I saw the buzzers story
yesterday and Jose Altuve came out
through Scott Boras and vehemently
denied of course he's going to be a
mentally deny this but what do you make
is there weather smoke there's fire here
I say no I mean you have to be careful
and not look at these things at the
confirmation bias I mean nobody thought
at the time and saw anything that said
why is weird that he's not taking his
jersey off after walk-off homer now that
it's out there from the Twitter
detectives we're looking at it with a
different eye I do know that reports
were out there suspicions that wrote
that the Astros were wearing bandages
with buzzers on them the Commissioner's
Office in this three-month investigation
did look into that and found nothing
commissioner said that on the record
they specifically looked at that found
nothing
TV gave his reasons for not taking who
serves the up after the game to Ken
Rosenthal in real-time where he said
listen my wife doesn't like me do it
happened for I'm a modest guy I'm not
comfortable with it that's his answer
that's good enough for me at that time
until somebody actually comes up with
real evidence and not confirmation bias
yeah but if I rip off your Jersey you
got an undershirt on there it's not like
he was naked and so you're saying
anytime he's in a t-shirt that he's
embarrassed or he's he's modest and
doesn't what does he walk around with
his jersey on all the time or long I
mean I'm not buying that part of it
where hey I'm modest okay he hit a
game-winning home run he homered off
Chapman and his thought is don't rip off
my jersey come on he's already a proven
cheater and now you got that I'm not
buying that maybe they didn't use
buzzers Tom but I'm not buying that yeah
I think it was something he didn't walk
off home run earlier with his wife she
told she didn't like it
and listen there's some guys who don't
wear t-shirts or anything underneath
their uniforms he might be one of those
I don't know
he's got a blue you got a blue he got
something on Yvonne I know he's got a
sleeve on but in many cases you saw Pete
Alonzo sometimes you're wearing
something underneath or you know they'll
rip everything off so listen again what
do you have incidents like this and as
you know there's so many echoes here
with the steroid era once you put it out
there that players are pushing the
envelope and cheating it puts everything
under suspicion and that's really the
worst thing about that it's what we know
and then it's what we guess is it a
great to come on and talk about your
sport when it there's a scandal on it's
been a heck of a week I mean one after
the other I will tell you this and this
is not defensive baseball cause it's
been a bad week but I did think they
they did a good job with transparency
with that report at least nobody walked
away from that saying what are they
hiding what actually happened with the
Astros and seventeen and eighteen now 19
is going to be a different story that's
going to continue but we still have to
hear about the Red Sox in 18 well at
least pretty pretty much laid it out
there after talking to more than 60
people and 70,000 emails I think they
learned their lesson from the Pete Rose
thing where if you're going to suspend
somebody like this you better show your
evidence but don't you Pete coming out
Pete Rose saying hey at least I didn't
taint the game I went come on
what's worse what Pete Rose did or what
the Astros did I think they're both
really better any time you call into
question the integrity of the outcome of
the game I mean that's probably the
worst thing that could happen in a sport
right when you go to a game you pay your
money you're watching it on TV if
there's even any suspicion in your mind
that the outcome was decided by
something outside of the rules what do
you have you get you have professional
wrestling I mean there's no integrity to
the competition at that point so I'm not
gonna split hairs and say one was worse
than the other because they drive it
really the heart of the game you're
gonna be part of MLB network's exclusive
Hall of Fame coverage on Tuesday that
will be when we talk some more about
steroids what do you think the biggest
discussion will be on that Tuesday when
you guys discuss the Hall of Fame I hate
to say it but it's probably bonds and
Clemens again
how close they get to 75% and they have
what just a year or two more left on the
ballot a couple of more shots and that's
it you know sub to that we know Jeter's
going in is that a hundred percent Larry
Walker and Curt Schilling are the bubble
guys whether they get in or not both of
them are going to be right there and
blockers it is last year so he needs to
get in at least by the writers ballot
this time but yeah the conversation
about is there any growth in terms of
support which there has been for Clemens
and bonds I think there will be I don't
think they're getting in this year but
the extrapolation of whether they're
continuing out of pace that's going to
get them in or not I'll leave you with
this what would you say to Dodger fans
today about losing to the Astros in the
World Series listen hang with him I
especially feel for somebody like
Clayton Kershaw right he goes into
Houston there he's got a four nothing
lead and everything blows up on him at
Minute Maid Park and we don't know what
pitches the Astros got or how it
influenced the game but we know it was
used throughout the postseason and that
has to hurt but I will tell you dad that
when the Astros sat down with
investigators and multiple Astros told
them named at least eight other teams
who were doing this in 2017 not in the
postseason but in the 2017 season I
think they're accurate about that what
you had replay system in real time with
a camera dedicated on home plate for
every team of the major leagues
we know that the Astros weren't the only
team so just be careful about how far
you want to go out there and saying that
our house is clean great stuff tom and
congratulations again of going into the
broadcasting Hall of Fame well deserved
and I'll see you in in June in
winston-salem North Carolina I look
forward to it Congrats man thank you Tom
Tom Verducci senior baseball writer
works for the MLB Network for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]